this is what it looks like to drive
through
Wyoming for about 400
[Music]
miles about the only thing you'll see
during the first 4 and 1/2 hours are the
towns of Rock Springs and Rollins
populations 23,000 and 8,000
respectively hopefully you aren't prone
to boredom because quite frankly there's
nothing to
see despite being larger than the United
Kingdom Wyoming is home to less than
600,000 people about 177% of 1% of the
US
population and this Emptiness is no
accident sponsored by nebula the
exclusive home to my original series
China actually stay tuned for a new
episode coming
soon Cole is the lifeblood of
Wyoming the cowboy state alone produces
40% of America's supply three times more
than Second Place West Virginia and over
50% more than all of
Appalachia the north antalope relle mine
in the state's northeast corner is the
largest open pit coal mine in the world
it operates on two 12-hour shifts rain
or shine 365 days a
year without it the economy and indeed
the Wyoming way of life would soon
collapse
apps though not as you might assume for
lack of jobs truth be told there are
only about 5,000 coal miners left in the
state the loss of these high-paying jobs
certainly wouldn't help but even the
incomprehensibly massive North analou
mine only employs about 1,00 people
0.1% of the state's
population no the real reason why oming
needs coal are Severance
taxes for every $100 worth of coal oil
and gas produced in the state between
six and $65 are siphoned into the public
purse creating an enormous budget
surplus rather than redistribute this
wealth directly as annual dividends as
Alaska does the people of Wyoming have
chosen low
taxes in any given year its average
household pays only about 3,500 $ in
property sales and use taxes but
receives about
$27,000 worth of services including
Education Health Care and
infrastructure in other words Wyoming
residents receive an 80 to 90% discount
on public services all thanks to fossil
fuels but this unusual Arrangement has
some unusual
implications imagine you move move to
say North
Dakota this line represents your
contributions to the state in the form
of taxes and this one the services you
receive in
return what this graph by The Economist
Dr Peter evangelicas shows is that new
residents have a slightly positive
effect on the state budget on average
and in the vast majority of States
newcomers give more than they
take now let's say you move to nearby
Wyoming there you'd still consume one
person's worth of
resources yet because its tax rates are
so low you wouldn't add much additional
Revenue new residents are a massive
drain on its
budget coal is finite the larger the
population the less Pi is left for
everyone simply put its taxpayers have a
uniquely strong incentive to keep their
State
empty while nearly every region of
America has slowly urbanized including
red States like Arkansas Texas and Idaho
Wyoming stands apart as one of the last
true remnants of the Wild West in 1980
it was the 49th most populous state in
the Union today it's the 50th in those
40 years its net population grew by just
2552 people a year on aage
average there is no Austin Texas island
of liberalism or Bentonville Arkansas
pocket of urban growth every inch of
Wyoming remains just
Wyoming and this resistance to change is
not limited to demographic
growth take clean energy for example in
the last 15 years wind farms have
rapidly proliferated across the United
States and not just including but
especially in traditionally red States
like Texas Oklahoma and
Kansas but not
Wyoming between 2011 and 19 the amount
of wind power generated by the cowboy
state actually decreased by nearly
10% as few new turbines were built while
many were taken out of
service in a 2023 survey of eight
Western States five red and three blue
Wyoming was the only one where a
majority of respondents preferred to
maximize not reduce the need for coal
oil and
gas Wyoming makes Montana look like a
Bastion of Prius driving
liberals but all this may be about to
change on August 30th 2022 it became
clear California was about to experience
one of its hottest weeks in
history 100 plus degree temperatures
were forecast every day for the greater
Los Angeles region home to nearly 20
million
Americans extreme heat would surely lead
to extreme use of air conditioning one
of the biggest consumers of
electricity this line represents energy
use on a typical summer day this one the
record for all of
2021 and these actual usage between
August 31st and September 6th last
year at the same time electricity Supply
was seriously
constrained blistering temperatures led
to droughts droughts led to wildfires
and wildfires to smoke which reduced the
efficiency of solar panels by roughly
30% droughts also brought water levels
to record lows and reservoirs across the
state including the Hoover dams Lake me
a major source of power for Southern
California if this unusually large
demand looked as though it might exceed
this unusually low Supply even
momentarily State officials would have
no choice but to initiate
blackouts and on Tuesday this nightmare
scenario seemed
inevitable by late afternoon Sacramento
San Jose Santa Rosa Redwood City
Livermore Napa and King City had all
tied or broken their all-time heat
records sports games were cancelled
recess was held inside and bart trains
operated at reduced speed in case tracks
were warped by
heat a few minutes before 5 as
Californians began returning home from
work demand for electricity set a new
state record flirting with the edge of
Supply in a panic Governor Gavin Nome
sent an emergency text message begging
residents to reduce their
usage either thousands of households
would voluntarily turn down their AC's
on the hottest day of the year or the
state was about to experience its third
major blackout in 20
years it worked barely within minutes
about 2,000 megawatt of demand
disappeared nearly averting
crisis but harder times lie ahead like
many states California is planning for a
clean energy future by 2026 half of its
electricity must come from renewable
sources followed by 60% in 2030 and 100
% by
2045 that means a greater Reliance on
solar and Hydro power both of which are
weakened at the precise moment energy
use is at its highest hot summer
days to achieve its climate goals
without repeating the events of last
September California needs help in short
there's a huge market for the right kind
of energy at the right time of day and
Wyoming it turns out has just what
California
needs cruel Relentless wind is a fact of
life in
Wyoming its narrow mountain ranges and
high plateaus create thousands of
natural funnels for jet streams which
blow wind Eastward across the United
States when these funnels are
perpendicular to highways as is the case
here on I25 south of Wheatland wind can
so violently strike the side of a car or
semi as to flip it
over this happens surprisingly
frequently as seen in this video which
resulted miraculously in zero
injuries with its high altitude Prairie
in sparse human habitation there's
simply nothing to Slow Wind Down
allowing it to reach 65 M an hour or
faster at which point roads are
typically
closed while this effect creates some
White Knuckle driving it's perfect for
wind
farms wind speeds are classified between
one poor and seven
superb half of all six and seven class
wind in the nation is located in Wyoming
and most of that in just a few counties
around the state's Southeast
Corner not only that but its wind is
strong when California is the weakest
right here in the
afternoon and when the sun is down on
the the West Coast the Wyoming wind is
working
overtime this unlikely alliance between
the country's largest and one of its
most liberal states and its smallest
most conservative one has the power to
radically transform the American West
the only thing that stands in the way is
an arduous bureaucratic Maze of federal
state and County
regulations in 2010 the state of Wyoming
reclassified wind farms as industrial
fac facilities requiring that they go
through the same permitting process as
those involving for example radioactive
waste only after submitting a 400 plus
page application paying up to $100,000
in fees and holding a public hearing can
a wind developer proceed to step two
submitting another application this time
to the
county at any point in this process any
person or organization with a Wyoming
address can challenge the permit giving
Nim's free reign to slow or halt
progress then there's the federal
bureaucracy no fewer than six such
departments administer Wyoming land
mainly the Bureau of Land
Management in the 1880s the US
government incentivized the construction
of new railroads by granting those
companies land on either side of the
tracks in hopes that this land would
then be sold to individual settlers
rather than large companies it was given
to the railroads in alternating square
mile
sections the result is a checker board
of public and private land in windy
Southern
Wyoming since four squares of BLM land
surround every one patch of private land
dealing with the feds is simply
unavoidable add all this up and any
attempt to tap into this Treasure Trove
of wind power should be dead in the
water who would gamble hundreds of
millions of dollars in upfront costs
alone in the hopes that America's most
conservative state would sign off on
clean energy and that not one of a dozen
counties or hundreds of land owners
would veto the
project enter billionaire oil tycoon
Republican Mega donor and future owner
of America's largest wind farm Philip
anets his plan is to build a thousand
turbines capable of powering a million
homes on 320,000 acres in a place named
for coal Carbon
County a $3 billion 700m transmission
line will then connect this wind farm to
California through Colorado Utah and
Nevada it took 18 years to secure the
permits but approval was finally granted
Against All Odds this
spring today after a 10-year stagnation
Wyoming wind is making a
comeback about eight other farms are in
development with most set to become
operational in the next 2
years only one question remains will the
people of Wyoming allow
it in the 1970s the term National
sacrifice Zone was coined to describe
places like
Wyoming out here on the country's remote
Frontier a few Americans would endure
the sight smell and symptoms of coal so
that many more could enjoy its
fruits in return these areas were well
compensated with high salaries and low
taxes but for some wind represents an
unwelcome renegotiation of that implicit
trade according to the University of
Wyoming wind will bring somewhere
between 3 and 9,000 jobs to the state
not at all an insignificant
amount the overwhelming majority however
are short-term construction jobs
building access roads transporting parts
and installing
equipment in the long term there may
only be 500 to 1500 operations and
maintenance roles a drop in the bucket
compared to coal oil and
gas now Wyoming residents are powerless
to stop the spread of green energy just
as Global oil prices have long dictated
the state of its
economy but there is one thing they can
do tax it Wyoming is already the only
state in the Union with a wind tax
currently $1 per megawatt hour several
politicians have proposed raising it to
2 three four or even
$5 it's effectively playing a high
stakes game of chicken with wind
developers Wyoming is betting that its
wind is so good that investors will
swallow the extra cost and if it works
the tax could breathe new life into
Wyoming's dying economy by introducing a
new source of Revenue the state could
begin weaning itself off of fossil
fuels but if Wyoming overplays its hand
and developers take their money to
Colorado or New Mexico instead its
economy could be left more dependent on
coal than
ever perhaps the place in the world most
similar to Wyoming is BTO China in fact
it's hard to distinguish these clips of
its coal mines from those of Wyoming's
North anope
mine BTO is also in all likelihood where
the rare earth metals found in the
device you're watching this fairy video
on
originated for years China was accused
of artificially subsidizing their
production for political control but the
real reason for China's near Monopoly is
much more
complicated find out why in my six-part
original series China actually
exclusively available on
nebula nebula is what happens when
channels like polymatter real life lore
real engineering and Windover
Productions are given extra resources
and freedom from the algorithm longer
better and higher Production videos than
we could ever make on
YouTube Take a Look for example at
modern conflicts these are 20 30 50
minute highly researched deep dives into
recent Global conflicts this is an
insane amount of Premium content and yet
it's just one of dozens of Originals all
ail ailable for just a few bucks a month
normally five bucks a month but you can
get it for 50% off that's just $2.50 a
month by clicking the link on screen or
in the
description